>>Male #1: All right, welcome to another Author
at Google presentation.
We're lucky to have Rob Reid with us today.
Rob is a writer and technology entrepreneur
based in Los Angeles and San Francisco.
Rob is the founder, CEO and chairman of Listen.com,
the online music company that developed the
Rhapsody music service.
Rhapsody has since been spun into an independent
company
and has over a million paying subscribers.
Notably, Listen was the first online company
to secure full catalog licenses
from ALL the major labels.
Rob joins us today as the author of the novel,
Year Zero.
It's a novel about aliens with a mad passion
for human music.
However, unlike Listen.com, the aliens did
not secure licenses for the music they love,
and the novel chronicles the ensuing intergalactic
copyright standoff.
Rob's other writings have included a cover
story for Wired magazine,
as well as prominent features in publications,
including The Wall Street Journal,
Business 2.0, and The Glider Technology Report.
He's also written for countless websites,
including Ars Technica,
Wired.com and TED.com
>>Rob Reid: Thank you kindly.
[Applause]
Uh, so as mentioned today I want to talk about
two topics
that go together as naturally as peanut butter
and jelly,
vodka and caviar for you Russians, chocolate
and mayonnaise for you weirdos,[laughter]
and of course it's aliens and copyright law.
And also about my book, which is about aliens
and copyright law.
I want to start by showing you a quick video
that at the very last few seconds brings those
two topics together
as well as I could possibly do it for you
today at this moment.
And while it does seem probably unoriginal
and even perhaps plagiaristic
to start with a video instead of speaking
one's self,
in this case, maybe not because the video
is of me.
It's just better edited than anything I'm
going to do right now.
It's a very brief TED talk that I gave at
the most recent TED conference in Long Beach,
which incidentally feels like it's populated
entirely by Google employees at this point.[laughter]
It's a quick intro to my perspective on copyright
law
and how, at the very tail end of this video,
it relates to aliens
and here it is and I will chitter chatter
a little bit afterward.
Hopefully this will go right up.
[video plays, whooshing noise and music starts]
[applause]
>>Rob Reid: The recent debate over copyright
laws, like SOPA in the United States
and the ACTA agreement in Europe has been
very emotional.
And I think some dispassionate quantitative
reasoning could really bring a great deal
to the debate.
I therefore would like to propose that we
employ, that we enlist the cutting edge field
of copyright math whenever we approach this
subject.
For instance, just recently the Motion Picture
Association revealed that our economy
loses fifty-eight billion dollars a year to
copyright theft.
Now rather than just argue about this number,
a copyright mathematician will analyze it.
And he'll soon discover that this money could
stretch from this auditorium
all the way across Ocean Boulevard to the
Westin and then to Mars--
[laughter] if we use pennies.
[laughter]
Now this is a powerful, some might say dangerously
powerful insight.
But it's also a morally important one.
Because this isn't just the hypothetical retail
value of some pirated movies that we're talking
about,
but this is actual economic losses.
This is equivalent to the entire American
corn crop failing along with all of our fruit
crops
as well as wheat, tobacco, rice, sorghum--whatever
sorghum is-- [laughter] losing sorghum [laughter].
But identifying the actual losses to the economy
is almost impossible to do unless we use copyright
math.
Now, music revenues are down about eight billion
a year since Napster first came on the scene.
So that's a chunk of what we are looking for.
But total movie revenue across theaters, home
videos and pay per view are up, and T.V. and
satellite
and cable revenues are WAY up.
Other content markets like book publishing
and radio are also up,
so this small missing chunk here is puzzling.
[Laughter]
Since the big content markets have grown in
line with historic norms
it's not additional growth that piracy has
prevented.
Copyright math tells us that it must be foregone
growth in a market that has no historic norms.
One that didn't exist in the '90's.
What we are looking at here is the insidious
cost of ringtone piracy.
[laughter]
Fifty billion dollars of it a year, which
is enough at thirty seconds a ring tone that
could stretch from here to Neanderthal times.
[Laughter]
[applause]
It's true.
I have Excel.
[Laughter]
The movie folks also tell us that our economy
loses over 370,000 jobs to content theft
which is quite a lot when you consider back
in '98, the Bureau of Labor statistics
indicated that the motion picture and video
industries were employing 270,000 people.
[laughter]
Other data has the music industry at about
45,000 people,
and so the job losses that came with the Internet
and all that content theft
had therefore left us with negative employment
in our content industries.
[laughter]
This is just one of the many mind blowing
statistics
that copyright mathematicians have to deal
with everyday
and some people think the String Theory is
tough.
[laughter]
Now this is a key number from the copyright
mathematician’s tool kit,
it's the precise amount of harm that comes
to media companies
whenever a single copyrighted song or movie
gets pirated.
Hollywood and Congress derived this number
mathematically
back when they last sat down to improve copyright
damages and
and made this law.
Some people think this number's a little bit
large
but copyright mathematicians who are media
lobby experts
are merely surprised that it doesn't get compounded
for inflation every year.
[laughter]
Now when this law first passed, the world's
hottest mp3 players could hold just ten songs.
It was a big Christmas hit because what little
hoodlum wouldn't want
a million and half bucks worth of stolen goods
in his pocket.
[laughter]
[applause]
These days, an iPod classic can hold 40,000
songs,
which is to say eight billion dollars worth
of stolen media--
[laughter]
[applause]
-- or about 75,000 jobs.
[Laughter]
[applause]
Now you might find copyright math strange,
but that's because it's a field
best left to experts.
So that's it for now, I hope you'll join me
next time when I will be making
an equally scientific and fact based inquiry
into the cost of alien music piracy
to the American economy.
Thank you very much.
[Applause and cheers]
Thank you.
[applause]
[video ends]
[music sounds]
>>Rob Reid: [inaudible]
[coughing in audience]
God it was so easy when it was shown to me,
I go to detect displays--what do I go to?
Open display preferences right?
We come here, we stop mirroring, oh this is
sweet.
And then I pull up my power point presentation
and I do that.
That was easy.
Did that work?
All right.
so I know that with Google translate and all
the local edition things that you guys do,
all your local initiatives, Google is a real
master of localization
and I wanted to honor that tradition when
I came here by basically localizing a little
bit
of what you just saw to put it in Google terms.
Now the first thing is I'm sure you remember
this very meaningful
and powerful info graphic from the TED talk.
I stayed up until the wee hours last night
writing some very very precise astro-physical
calculations
and I can confirm to you that 58 billion dollars
in pennies is just enough to connect this
building
to Mars as well.
[Laughter]
It helps quite a bit if Mars is at perihelion,
but still this is equally relevant to you
as it was to the TED crowd.
Another thing, obviously, I made this observations
based on the iPod Classic.
I know how you guys feel about Apple around
here--
[laughter]
--so I just decided to translate this into
Google terms, with the Nexus 7.
Now the Nexus 7 only has sixteen gigs max
storage instead of a hundred and sixty,
so it can merely carry eight hundred million
dollars of stolen merchandise
and rob us of seventy-five hundred jobs BUT
if we give one of these things,
and I'm sure that will happen to every employee
of Google and Motorola,
we're looking at seventy-two trillion dollars
worth of economic losses
and to put that into perspective that's enough
money to go to the nearby
Maritime Hotel, expanded slightly admittedly,
and we could check in
the entire populations of Burlington, VT with
this money;
Fresno, CA, and still have room for everybody
in Asia.
[laughter]
And for slightly more than two months, and
if we throw in the breakfast buffet
a little bit less than two months.
So that's my little localization effort.
I hope that was helpful.
[laughter]
And now I'm just going to talk a little bit
Year Zero.
A couple of things were previously mentioned,
but just to go over them.
Year Zero is the story of vast alien civilization
that is so into human pop music
that they inadvertently commit the biggest
copyright infringements
since the Big Bang, thereby bankrupting the
entire universe.
All the wealth in our universe is owed to
us and to our record labels
and we humans don't quite know it just yet
at the beginning of the book.
You will all be delighted to know, I hope,
that the book is about two-thirds set in present
day New York,
the rest is rambling across many galaxies
and so forth in the way that we like to do
in science fiction.
Now the aliens are in trouble because for
reasons that are baked deep
into the storyline--and we'll all just save
a ton of time
by suspending our disbelief on this point
for one moment--
but for reasons that are baked deep into the
storyline,
they are obligated to honor our copyright
laws.
And they're also obligated to pay the fines
and penalties
that are associated with our copyright laws
which they have violated in an unbelievably
big way.
And this is a problem because to quote
the most authoritative source on this subject
that exists, which is my own book:
American copyright laws are, quote "the most
cynical, predatory,
lopsided, and shameless money grubbing copyright
laws written by any society
anywhere in the universe since the dawn of
Time itself."
Now that's not my opinion, that's the opinion
of one of the aliens in my book.
[laughter]
And it may sound like a strangely emphatic
statement to you until you consider
the statistic which was cited in the TED talk
that the maximum fine for pirating a single
copy of a single song
is $150,000, which to put that into perspective,
in this state of New York,
the maximum fine for drunk driving is 1/300th
of that amount.
Which makes sense if, and only if, you believe
that while drunk driving does indeed have
terrible consequences, music piracy--again
quoting my authoritative source--
leads quickly to meth addiction, cannibalism,
and societal collapse.
Which is presumably what Congress was thinking
when they passed that rather crazy law.
So, what happens in the book is that a self-appointed
alien delegation comes to earth
to try to fix this terrible situation and
they quickly establish that the only way
they can do this is to reverse this complex
thicket of laws and international treaties
that literally go back centuries.
And they quickly determine that the only way
they can do this
is to recruit a very very powerful human ally
to help them navigate human society
and help them achieve this almost impossible
task.
And so they're thinking, "Who do we get?"
And they decide, "We gotta get somebody
who has two very rare but important attributes."
First of all, it has to be someone
who has unbelievable artistic credibility
because they presume that we revere
our musicians as much as they do.
We don't, but they're aliens
and they don't understand us very well, so
that's the first thing they're thinking:
"Ideally one of the greatest musicians who
ever lived--'A'--
and 'B' -- we need someone who has incredible
political might
who through sheer force of will can hopefully
reverse this entire legislative mess that
we have."
And so they think, you know, "Bono?"
That's kind of where they start,
and they're like, "Maybe we can do better
than that,"
and they dig a little bit further, they get
onto Google you'll be happy to know,
and they discover the most powerful media
law firm, on the entire earth is called
Carter, Geller, and Marks.
And at Carter--I made it up by the way--
and at Carter, Geller and Marks there is this
young attorney named Nick Carter,
and they're like "Bingo!
We got ourselves a Backstreet Boy!"
Because there was a Backstreet Boy named Nick
Carter--and they know this because they're
into our music--
So they come to earth and they present themselves
to Nick Carter.
They realize to their horror, he's not the
Backstreet Boy--he hates the Backstreet Boys
because the man has taste-- and he is not
the powerful partner who founded Carter, Geller
and Marks,
he just happens to have the same very common
last name as the powerful partner who founded
Carter, Geller and Marks.
He himself is merely a very low ranking copyright
attorney but it's too late--the Rubicon has
been crossed,
the die has been cast, the horse is out of
the barn, the low hand is into the Smirnoff.
It's over, pick your cliche, they are now
allied with Nick Carter, low ranking copyright
attorney.
He has forty-eight hours to reverse this whole
insane situation
or something very very bad is going to happen
to the earth.
And so, I've just summarized the first four
pages of the book [laughter]
and the next three hundred and fifty-three
pages can be summarized with three simple
words:
hilarity hopefully ensues.
So that's a little bit about Year Zero; it's
a little bit about copyright law.
I'd love to just have sort of a conversation
and take some questions
and I want to point out that this is technically
what they call, in the book promoting trade,
--oh actually I just want to kind of remind
you of one little thing--
I'm an expert in copyright math myself because
of the whole thing that I did
with Rhapsody and so I know you have a big
music initiative under way, there's actually
a lot of alumni from the company that I started,
Listen.com, who are working in music,
mainly in Mountainview--folks like Tim Quirk,
Zahavah Levine, and so forth,
so I know of what I speak when I talk about
copyright law so that's --both an entrepreneur
and an writer--and--more of an entrepreneur
than a writer, this is my first novel
and as I got into this, you know, and I started
talking to the folks at Random House
about what we do when the book comes out,
they said, “You should do a bunch of readings."
And I said, "That sounds great.
I can read."
And they said, "We want to tell you one important
thing, the last thing you should ever do at
a reading
is actually read from your book.
It's just a terrible mistake."
And so I'm going to ignore that advice just
very briefly, not because I believe life should
be about
taking risks, but because I think it's always
interesting to avoid excellent advice.
[laughter]
And I’m just going to do it briefly because
there's a couple passages here that I think
as fellow technology people you guys might
enjoy, so I'm actually going to violate all
rules,
read for a couple of minutes, and then we
can talk and do questions and that kind of
thing.
so I picked this passage because it's about
New York City, I grew up in Connecticut, I
spent some time
here in the city as well and I love it and
I feel like I kind of know it
and it's also about social media.
So what's happened here is that our hero Nick
Carter
has been visited by the alien delegation and
now he has been summoned
by somebody--he does not know who-- and it
turns out to be a bad guy alien who's wondering
who the hell this Nick Carter guy is and has
also come to earth,
and he's been summoned to some mysterious
restaurant in the meat packing district.
So he's left his office, it's about five o'clock,
and he says:
[Begins reading from Year Zero]
"Soon I was down on the icy bustling streets.
New York in February is New York at its worst,
unless you count those
hundred-degree August weekends when everybody's
off at the Hamptons but you."--there's a lot
of footnotes
in here.
He says, “Which I suppose you should count,
so let's call February New York at its almost
worst."--
He's a lawyer so he's always doing footnotes--"The
cheery buzz of the holidays is long gone
and the spring thaw is too distant to provide
any solace.
Add a three inch layer of blackened slush,
and it can feel like Moscow with out the twelve-cent
vodka.
I started walking toward the Meatpacking District.
Eight block on, I found a cab.
The crosstown traffic turned out to be so
bad that walking may have been faster.
But it was nice to get my stricken sinuses
out of the freezing rush-hour air."--he has
a cold, that turns out to be
really important to the plot, okay?
"As I settled into the backseat,
my phone started humming from a flurry of
inbound texts.
"OMG.
Eatiary?
I'm soooooo jealous.""--Eatiary is the restaurant
he's going to--
"That came from a girl I faintly remembered
from college.
Next in the queue was this from the cousin
of a long-ago roommate:
"You must must must have the Stuffed Marrow
Rings with Adzuki Bean reduction!!!"
And on it went--fifteen texts from distant
acquaintance, as well as an actual friend
or two.
After wondering if
everyone I knew was in on some ingenious belated
birthday prank, I figured out what was happening.
Flutter"--Flutter is spelled P-h-l-u-t-t-r--Phluttr.com--I
have the URL by the way--it cost me millions.--
[laughter]
"Phluttr is smartphone app that lets you trumpet
your every thought and action to an enraptured
world by pushing out
mini press releases via Facebook, Twitter,Google+,
SMS, email, and, for all I know, telegrams
and carrier pigeons.
Being this fascinating can be taxing, even
for clinical narcissists.
So Phluttr makes it easy
by infiltrating your phone and automatically
publishing whatever it learns.
In my first twenty minutes
of experimenting with the service, every classmate
and co-worker that I'd ever known was told
that
"Nick just arrived at 200 Park Avenue!" and,
"Nick just called United Airlines!' and, most
embarrassing,
"Nick is listening to 'Bye Bye Bye' by 'N
Sync!"" [laughter]--and this footnote--
"For the record, I was in a goofy mood, and
listened to it strictly for its kitsch value--but
good luck explaining the
concept of irony to a smartphone."
[laughter]
"However awful this sounds, the reality is
far worse, and I soon quit the service.
I'd since uninstalled its
diabolical software a dozen times, but somehow
it kept reappearing.
This time I thought I'd finally foiled it--by
quite literally buying a new phone.
But after a month's sulk, Phluttr was back.
It had apparently matched the
address that I'd looked up on my phone to
Eatiary (a faddish restaurant it seemed).
And once my GPS signal indicated
that I was actually heading there, it had
informed my breathless public."
[stops reading from book]
So what's funny about that passage is I wrote
it about two years ago because in the physical
publishing world, it
still takes like a year to get from the point
where everything's done, they've bought your
book, they're excited to
release it, the book is, you know, written,
and it actually gets out so, I wrote this
over eighteen months, I sold it
a year ago.
And when I wrote this, this was so completely
surreal and impossible that my wife and I
just giggled
every time we read it and, and it just seems
to be like six months off now, Phluttr.
So anyway that was--that's basically the main
passage that I wanted to read to you guys.
I am very happy to take questions and chit
chat or let you thunder off to lunch or whatever
it is.
There's two microphones, please ask questions
if there are any.
Here we go.
Yes sir.
>>Male #2: Thanks for having me here.
I'm Patrick.
You know, I worked
with you guys back in early 2000, and it's
so--back there where licensing, music copyrights
at Listen at the time, do
you feel anything's changed in the last ten
years since then?
>>Rob Reid: Yeah.
What's changed is the labels are now--and
it's a big change--the labels are now willing
to license.
And I think that the original sin, in a sense,
of the music labels in the world of internet
based music
was essentially a five year embargo that they
put on the market, a five year boycott on
their music from the
Internet.
And I think that is more to blame for the
piracy phenomena that followed than anything
else
and so essentially what happened was in late
1998, the first mass market mp3 player, the
Diamond Multimedia Rio,
was announced.
At that point, I was just in the initial phases
of starting the company and started going
around on
bended knee to the music labels , hoping to
get licenses.
And I knew it was going to be bad when, within
thirty days
of the release of this device, the music industry
sued Diamond Multimedia in an attempt to make
mp3 players illegal
in this country.
Had they succeeded, it would have been one
of those things: automatic weapons, yes; mp3
players, no,
in terms of legal devices.
And for the subsequent five years, the labels
not only sued everything that moved in the
broader market, but they refused to license
their content to anybody who came along and
said, "We want to create, you
know, a legal substitute that people can buy
as opposed to steal."
Now the problem with that was many-fold.
It was basically April of '03 I think, before
the iTunes music store
launched.
We launched before that with an unlimited
streaming service, but the world was maniacally
focuses on
downloads at that point, what the world wanted
was downloads.
And so you had this almost five year period
when this radically useful and fabulous and
fascinating and flexible format came out and
the labels were simply not
selling that . During that interim, it basically
amounted to a training period, which lasted
about five years,
where people were being trained in being very
technically adept at piracy and they were
frankly trained at frankly
being very morally comfortable with it--"I
want this thing, it's not for sale.
I'd sure buy it if it were, but it
ain't.
I'm gonna grab it and I'm gonna learn how
to get music in this manner."
So that is when the piracy phenomena got very
very deeply baked I think into social norms,
social norm practices,
and the music industry is still paying the
price for that.
What's very different today is that the labels
are willing to license, so there is much more
a proliferation
of services that are out there.
I think that a lot of pretty inventive services
that really could
trigger a lot more music sales, trigger a
lot more discovery, are still not being licensed.
I mean my favorite example, there's a great
service called Tiny Song which is a lot like
Bitly or Tiny URL, but
for music.
What happens is, you got to Tiny Song, you
type in a song that you'd like to Tweet out
or email or
broadcast in some other manner to a lot of
people.
It kicks back this tiny URL, you put that
in your Twitter or other
feed, and anybody who sees it clicks it, it
goes immediately to a Groove shark page, and
that song starts playing
immediately.
That's a really cool way to say, "Hey everybody,
check out this song."
They're being sued.
>>Male #2: Yeah.
>>Rob Reid: And so it's not perfect in the
licensing area, but at least they are licensing.
There are a lot of
wonderful companies, yourselves included,
that are able to do at least some things with
music
and that's the huge huge huge change, but
it came five years too late.
>>Male #2: Yeah, it was interesting times.
I worked at the NMPA at Harry Fox, that was
supportive of the suit
back with the Rio Diamond, and I had it at
work and people looked at me like "Oh my God,
he just brought in the
devil."
[Rob laughs] And I had to hide it.
>>Rob Reid: It was like you had brought in
a handgun or something.
>>Male #2: Yeah yeah yeah, and worse.
>>Rob Reid: Or heroin.
>>Male speaker 2: Yeah worse they framed it
that way but you know it's interesting today
in Google, our business
within Google supports Google Play and YouTube
and other clients outside, but we manage about
forty million sound
recordings that come through the systems,
from various--and about seventy-seven thousand
publishing companies that we
license and you know you got that one publisher
and they just look at you like--they're looking
at you
like you're an alien so you know, listening
to this story and about your book is incredible,
but we live it everyday
but it's--the world's still light years away
from changing.
>>Rob Reid: It's still a mess yeah.
>>Male #2: Yeah.
>>Rob Reid: Yeah, it is still a mess.
Yes sir?
>>Male #3: I was wondering, it seems like
very since iTunes came out, the labels were
pretty comfortable
with downloads.
You know, like you said, not at first, but
eventually they came around, but what about
streaming,
I mean, you've got services today like Spotify,
and they're still missing a lot of "A list"
artists
and do you think that the labels will ever
really be on board with streaming or is that
just--what are your thoughts
on the labels and streaming?
>>Rob Reid: Ironically, the labels were okay
with streaming believe it or not before they
were okay with downloads,
so we were--Rhapsody launched as an 'all you
can eat' streaming service.
We're kind of--when the history of downloadable
music is eventually written, we may be viewed
as the kind
of VisiCalc of the 'all you can eat' streaming
service.
We're still out there, I think we're still
number three
in the market, but Spotify has definitely
leapfrogged us, or leaptfrogged us, or whatever,
however you would say that
grammatically flawlessly.
So they did actually license to us before
they got there, quite a while before it was
the better part of a year
after we got all five of the major label licenses,
before the iTunes store was licensed.
And that story about how Steve Jobs had a
brawl and so forth to get that done is very
well documented in the
Isaacson book and elsewhere.
The holes in our catalog and everybody else's
catalog--when I say our, I sold
Rhapsody a long long time ago to Real Networks,
they sold half of it to MTV--I'll say our
forever.
It's not like an affectation, I just can't
stop myself, I feel very allied to Rhapsody.
But the holes in our catalog and Spotify's
catalogs usually, believe it or not, have
more to do with things that are
at the artist or the publisher level.
At this point, the labels are pretty much,
are very much on board like "We want
to get everything in there" but there are
weird glitches in certain contracts that prevent
that.
So I think that it's more just--and the holes
diminish, asymptotically approaching zero,
but asymptotically, it's
never going to be zero.
It's always going to be closer and closer
and closer.
The holes were just gaping five or six years
ago.
They're more--they're almost weird when you
come across them now
in the streaming catalogs, and there's a few
holes in the download catalogs as well.
>>Male #3: I think until you have names like
The Beatles in there, everyone will perceive
there still being
holes.
>>Rob Reid: Yeah Yeah.
And The Beatles were also the last people
to get on CD's as well.
And the last people, very famously
the last people to get on Apple.
I believe they'll grudgingly come over at
some point.
And my personal belief is that the streaming
model is finally entering the steep part of
its curve.
If you go on campuses now streaming has become
so wide spread because of the friction free
exploration
that it enables and I think that the key thing
was that the streaming services, like Spotify
and Rhapsody
and others have finally kind of got portability
more or less nailed, with sort of caching
to the device and
people want to get the music off of the Internet
and into their lives.
And so fixing that was a key thing.
My belief is that about, you know, in the
five-ish year standpoint, I bet that streaming
dollar share
is very close and maybe even exceeds downloadable,
but, man, were we ten years too early.
Yes sir?
>>male #4: So it seems to me there's a bit
of fundamental distinction between the music
and the video
situation.
In particular, I'm thinking about Netflix,
where they have the streaming service and
they have physical
DVD service.
And the CEO for some reason wants to get rid
of the physical DVD service in favor of the
streaming
service, even though the streaming service
in the long run cannot make any money because
the companies will just
keep raising what they charge Netflix.
>>Rob Reid: Yeah.
>>male #4: Is there a distinction there, in
that the music streaming business can make
money,
where as the video streaming business can't?
Is there a reason for that, or--and is there
a reason why the music
download business can make money where as
maybe music streaming or video streaming can't?
>>Rob Reid: They're all really really tough
businesses from a margin standpoint for the
simple reason that
you need the permission of the majors to be
in business.
If you're missing even a single major label,
of which there
are now three, there used to be five, the
gaps in your catalog are so vast
there's just a great deal of leverage that's
on the studio or the label's side
when you're negotiating your terms.
Particularly if the whole point of your service
is "We've got everything,
and you can explore in a friction free way.
"
And generally speaking, almost without exception,
and indeed probably without exception, these
deals are cut for
twelve or twenty-four month basis, the tendency
will be, I believe, it has been in the past
that as certain of these services manage to
make a little bit of money,
the labels and the studios are going to see
that, for--because they've actually have reporting
requirements that they cook into
their deals.
And they're going to claw back that margin,
and claw back that margin, and claw back that
margin,
and so I think that the margin dynamics are
similarly grim in both sides of the business.
The area in which they're not so bad--and
each business has it's little way of still
kind of surviving--for us
in streaming it's what they call breakage,
breakage is kind of weird usage; it's a weird
choice of a word,
for a concept that basically says, "You are
going to have that person.
God bless him or her, who pays for your
service and really never uses it."
And that's by the way, the way that like health
clubs
stay in business, and airline frequent flier
programs, and a whole bunch of other places.
So that's the advantage that the streaming
service has.
The advantage that download services have
is there's
some margin baked in, it's not bad, it's probably
like twenty-five to thirty percent gross points
which a lot of people make a living off of
that so there's something built in there.
The place that actually I think that has the
best margin dynamics is Pandora, because there
are essentially government set rates on what
can be charged
for non-interactive services, basically this
goes way back to the '20's when there was
the brawl between the earliest music broadcasters--AM
radio in those days--and the record labels
and the government basically came in and said
"Okay, we're going to determine what those
payment rates are," and that tradition has
continued,
and so Pandora, by being a non-interactive
service, isn't, isn't nearly as much at the
mercy of the labels.
So there's little bit higher margins there,
but margins are kind of lousy, throughout
the business.
Because you do, the labels are in a position
to "Oh man, they've gotten bandwidth is a
lot cheaper and they've done this that and
the other thing.
Let's up our rates a little bit."
I don't think these are ever going to be wildly
profitable businesses.
>>Male #4: Well Netflix, the physical DVD
side of the business, I don't think that the
labels can actually--
I think they have baked in that into the deals--
>>Rob Reid: Yeah.
>>Male #4: But fundamentally I don't think--you
can correct me if I'm wrong--I don't think
that they can legally restrict them from selling
some set--
>>Rob Reid: From selling some [unintelligible]
>>Male #4: Some set.
>>Rob Reid: That's a less regulated market
and that's an area where there is more wiggle
room, but I think there's also a general sense
that in --over the five to ten year period
the DVD is going to go the way of the CD.
And so that's, you know, to the extent that
there is a differential there it's temporary,
not temporary in the short term but in the
intermediate term, and then, man, that whole
business of Netflix separating its DVD's from
its streaming business was really a catastrophic
error.
It was a very very strange move at the corporate
level that their
stock price got hammered for.
And that's like a whole 'nother topic, but
it was clearly a weird move, as you indicated
for them to try to split the two and they
learned very quickly that that was a bad idea.
Any other questions?
No?
Well thank you very much for coming.
There are books back there, I'll sign them
or anything else you bring,
I'll linger and I'm happy to ask--to answer
questions one on one or whatever.
And thank you very much for coming out.
[Applause]